ted we have a developing situation in  the southwest valley tonight police are  responding to reports of gunshots at a  high school football game this was at  desert oasis high school orco man alive  now with more on what is a developing  situation orca  well brian metro police tell us no one  was injured and the scene here is secure  you can see that there are still a  couple police vehicles and crime scene  tape locking off part of the parking lot  by the football field police say a fight  broke out in the parking lot here at the  end of tonight's football game at desert  oasis high school during the fight  someone fired multiple shots into the  air and then that suspect ran off both  metro police and ccsd police responded  to the scene and secured the area as you  can imagine a little bit of a scary  situation here at desert oasis high  school at this football game but again  no one was injured reporting live in the  southwest valley tonight orca mana 8  news now